i'm
incredibly excited to see zack snyder
the snyder cut
because i i want to see the the extended
version
of all of zak's movies are always better
from watchmen to bvs to you name it it's
always
better um have you have you seen
anything of the snyder cut uh and
i have to ask are you doing any
additional photography for it
i knew you're gonna ask me this man and
um
i knew it um well by the way i'm asking
because i'm a legit fan
and i really want to know and yes i said
no
so we the fans want to know too i know
and they're going to go crazy and
they're going to come back at me with
whatever i say
so um you know i'll i can't you know
that's if if i was a part of it that
wouldn't be my it wouldn't be my place
to announce
that that would be zack's place
um so you know um
whether or not that's happening you know
that's that is not that is a
that is an answer that is above my
below my nda level or whatever you want
to call it
did we just lie and say that deathstroke
appears in archenemy so the 10 million
more people see it
yeah in the meantime you can go watch
archenemy it's you know you'll see some
similarities
just real quick though have you seen any
extra stuff did zach ever show you like
a longer version or you're going to be
have you seen any of that well look i
mean you know on my social
media i talked about you know there
there was an original
and credit sequence that was altered for
the release of
justice league once batman was canceled
they altered that scene so
here you go i mean it's it's you know
but i i wrote about that on my social
media
there's an original scene that will be
restored to us
you know to what it was originally